corona alarm eine uniklinik nämlich die
uniklinik düsseldorf schlägt tatsächlich
corona alarm das sind bilder von dort
aus der nach die klinik sagt wir sind
voll auf der intensivstation
in der nacht konnte man dort keine neuen
intensiv patienten mehr aufnehmen der
andrang war zu groß in den vergangenen
stunden in den vergangenen tagen die
aufnahme stationärer patienten wurde der
gestoppt in der notaufnahme gibt es noch
kapazitäten sagt die uni klinik aber
eben nicht auf der intensivstation was
heißt das jetzt alles für uns in dieser
schwieriger werdenden corona lage wenn
eine uni klinik jetzt eben tatsächlich
sagt ja intensivbetten derzeit
ausgelastet wir hören von steigenden
corona werden bundesweit und jetzt eben
dieser corona alarm begrenzt dort aus
düsseldorf müssen einmal ganz nüchtern
auf die fakten gucken patricia wie
schlimm ist tatsächlich die korona lage
aktuell in deutschland
vielen dank es ist eine kategorie die
eine zeitlang ganz fester bestandteil
unserer sendungen war das corona radar
dann konnten wir eine zeit lang diese
zahlen wieder vernachlässigen doch jetzt
jetzt ist es wieder soweit wir müssen
einen blick auf die zahlen werfen und
zwar auf alle zahlen nicht nur die
instanzen auf all die zahlen die wichtig
sind in dieser krise wir fangen
natürlich erst mal an mit den
neuansteckungen in deutschland da sehen
wir diese wellenbewegung da ging es hoch
und jetzt heute trauriger rekord 15
1513 neuansteckungen dass also der
negativrekord heute hier in deutschland
ganz ganz wichtige zahl in dieser krise
ist natürlich die zahl der
hospitalisierungen also die menschen die
derzeit mit corona im krankenhaus leben
liegen
2537 sind es gesamt und das zahlt sich
dann nochmal halbe-halbe auf in menschen
die beatmet werden müssen und im
menschen die das nicht müssen die also
derzeit im krankenhaus liegen in corona
mit corona werden hier das nochmal nach
bundesländern für sie aufgeteilt diese
karte finden sie natürlich auch zu jeder
zeit auf bild.de können dann ganz genau
nachschauen wie schaut es bei ihnen in
ihrem bundesland aus schauen wir uns
weitere zahlen an ganz entscheidend in
dieser krise natürlich die auslastung
der intensivbetten wir haben es eben
gerade gehört die uniklinik düsseldorf
die kommt da jetzt schon an ihre
belastungsgrenze deswegen ganz
entscheidende zahl in dieser krise
gemeldete betten 24
1726 haben wir in deutschland belegt
davon sind
21.100 14 natürlich nicht alle mit
corinna patienten deswegen auch hier
nochmal der blick ganz genau darauf
2537 corona patienten liegen derzeit auf
deutschlands intensivstationen und
insgesamt das ist auch eine ganz
wichtige zahl
1612 freie betten derzeit noch auch hier
sehen sie noch mal alle zahlen ganz
genau aufgeteilt nach den bundesländern
damit sie wissen wie es bei ihnen in
ihrem bundesland ausschaut schauen wir
deswegen einmal auf die hotspots schauen
wir auf die deutschlandkarte die wir vor
allen dingen monaten ja endlich mal
entspannt grün und gelb gesehen haben
wir sehen jetzt hat sie sich wieder roh
teilweise sogar dunkel rot eingefärbt
wir haben noch ein paar kleine grüne
gebiete vor allem im norden deutschland
dort liegt die instanz unter 50 wir
sehen aber auch einige dunkelrote
gebiete besonders hier unten dann im
osten von bayern östlich von münchen da
dann sogar eine instanz von über 500
auch diese karte jederzeit für sie auf
bild de abrufbar oder können sie genau
schauen wie es sogar in ihrem landkreis
aussieht können sich dadurch die karte
klicken wir schauen einmal auf die
todesfälle hier in deutschland und da
sehen wir jetzt wieder einen leichten
anstieg wir kommen hier von teilweise
über 1000 am tag und dann ging es runter
runter runter das hat natürlich mit den
impfungen was zu tun und dann sind wir
hier am heutigen tag bei 33 todesfällen
33 menschen die durch oder mit corona
gestorben sind ja diesem thema diesen
zahlen wollen wir jetzt weiter auf den
grund gehen und da gebe ich zurück
zurück nach teilweise nach teilweise
ja danke patricia die zahlen ganz
wichtig um die aktuelle corona lage eben
bewerten zu können das machen wir jetzt
mit dem chef der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft mit gerald gaß
denn neben den instanzen ist natürlich
vor allen dingen der blick in die
krankenhäuser immer wieder so wichtig
herr gast um wirklich zu wissen wird's
irgendwann knapp wird's irgendwann eng
ihnen erst mal schönen guten tag wir
hören jetzt heute aus düsseldorf diese
meldung düsseldorf die uni klinik sagt
wir können im moment nicht mehr
patienten aufnehmen auf der
intensivstation ist das nun
besorgniserregend wird es tatsächlich
eng auf deutschlands intensivstation
oder nur begrenzt dort in düsseldorf
zunächst auch mal von mir es ist im
moment begrenzt auf die stadt düsseldorf
gewesen in nordrhein westfalen gewesen
muss man sagen heute ist die situation
glücklicherweise schon wieder etwas
besser das heißt auch die uniklinik in
düsseldorf mit der ich heute morgen noch
gesprochen habe ist jetzt wieder in der
lage in begrenztem umfang intensiv
patienten aufzunehmen aber wir haben
wirklich eine besorgniserregende
situation die einfach darauf
zurückzuführen ist dass zu den normalen
intensivpatienten die wir üblicherweise
in großer zahl um diese jahreszeit haben
in diesem jahr eben nochmal jetzt wie
sie berichtet haben gut
2500 patienten patienten mit kobe dazu
kommen die auf intensivstation
beantworten das ist eine zusätzliche
belastung zu der saisonalen immer wohl
belastung im herbst und das bringt eben
eine regierung einige regionen an die
grenzen wobei nordrhein westfalen da
noch weniger stark betroffen ist als zb
bayern auch das haben sie eben in ihrer
karte gezahlt welche maßnahmen müssen
denn jetzt ergriffen werden er an dieser
entwicklung einhalt zu gebieten um vor
allem auch die krankenhäuser die
intensivstation nennen weiter ins
entlasten also wir sehen ganz deutlich
an den zahlen dass diejenigen die
geimpft sind ein wesentlich niedrigeres
risiko haben bei einer infektion ins
krankenhaus zu kommen die impfung
schützt also vor schweren verläufen doch
in großer in großem umfang das heißt wir
müssen unbedingt die booster impfung
voranbringen für die events länger als
sechs monate ihre impfung zurückliegen
haben das sind überwiegend die älteren
da muss ganz dringend mit den index in
die altenheime aber natürlich auch über
die niedergelassenen ärzte und
gegebenfalls müssen auch einzelne info z
und wieder eröffnet werden das ist das
erste das zweite ist wir müssen wissen
wer sich infiziert hat dh die beste
strategie muss ausgeweitet werden wir
sind auch dafür dass am arbeitsplatz
regelmäßig getestet wird bei denjenigen
die nicht geimpft sind auf jeden fall
und da muss auch der arbeitgeber wissen
wer ist denn eigentlich ist und nicht
gewiss darüber muss sich die politik
gedanken machen und ein weiterer aspekt
ist die krankenhäuser brauchen wie der
handlungssicherheit wir hatten im
letzten herbst einen rettungsschirm für
die krankenhäuser er läuft in diesen
tagen aus und ist bei weitem nicht mehr
so gespannt wie ihr das im letzten jahr
war deswegen auch die dringende bitte an
die politik hier zu reagieren damit die
krankenhäuser handlungsfähig werden ich
versuche mich noch mal so ein bisschen
klar zu kriegen diesen corona alarm
aktuell also wie eng ist es tatsächlich
auf den intensivstationen tatsächlich in
den krankenhäusern aktuell ist es in
keinem einzigen krankenhaus so dass
wirklich die lage dramatisch ist dass es
dort keine betten mehr gibt oder gibt es
diese krankenhäuser aktuell in
deutschland gas doch wir haben eine
ganze reihe von krankenhäusern über die
meldewege an den rettungsdienst sich
aktuell für notfall- und
intensivpatienten abgemeldet haben die
gibt es wo ist der rituelle sowohl wo
ist das der fall das ist überwiegend in
den ländern der fall die jetzt
tatsächlich auch sehr betroffen sind das
ist zb bayer stärker als in anderen
ländern der fall aber auch in sachsen
und thüringen wo zum teil dann auch
durchaus patienten überregional verlegt
werden müssen
und dass ihre einschätzung wenn wir dann
gesund bleiben und eben nicht in
krankenhäusern landet unser
weihnachtsfest in gefahr was glauben sie
das ist im moment schwer zu sagen aber
wir haben jetzt ist heute steigende ins
events zahlen und wir wissen in zehn bis
14 tagen kommen diese menschen dann in
teil eben auch in den krankenhäusern an
diese steigenden zahlen müssen wir
unbedingt brechen und deswegen
achten
hygienemaßnahmen masken und so weiter
auch als geimpfter einzuhalten und ich
kann auch nur an diejenigen abonnieren
die die kontrollen durchführen in der
gastronomie bei veranstaltung es muss
wirklich ernsthaft darauf geachtet
werden dass 2 und 3 g regeln eingeführt
werden dann bin ich durchaus
zuversichtlich dass wir ein
weihnachtsfest erleben können wie wir
uns das wünschen aber sicherlich auch
unter beachtung von hygienemaßnahmen
gibt es in der zeit genug pflegepersonal
in den kliniken
das pflegepersonal hat abgenommen wir
haben zwar keine flucht aus der fliege
aber wir haben die situation dass
zunehmend menschen die auf den
intensivstationen sitzt seit 20 monaten
in einer art ausnahmezustand arbeiten
ihre arbeitszeit reduzieren ungefähr 70
prozent der kliniken haben aktuell
weniger pflegepersonal in der summe
verfügbar als vor einem jahr das amt
werde um fragen der deutschen drang aus
wirtschaft ergeben und das beschränkt
natürlich unsere kapazitäten ebenfalls
dank an den chef der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft gerne gassi
heute am montagvormittag bei bild live
danke ich danke ihnen und wir habe
verstärkung bekommen bei uns im studio
nämlich unser bild chefreporter peter
thiede ist bei uns der seit beginn der
korona krise sich intensiv mit allen
zahlen allen hintergründen beschäftigt
schönen guten tag peter erst einmal
dieser corona alarm heute aus düsseldorf
und das was gerade gerald gaß von der
deutschen krankenhausgesellschaft sagt
bereitet die muss uns das jetzt sorgen
bereiten oder ist das doch alles im
bereich von kontrolliert geht alles noch
funktioniert alles noch wie ordnung ist
das aktuell 1 also sorgen muss einem das
machen aber akut gefährdet ist
deutschland jetzt meiner meinung nach
nicht wir sehen sie haben es eben gerade
in der antwort auf die letzte frage
gehört wir sehen einen mix aus
verschiedenen sachen natürlich nimmt
corona zu wir haben sehr viele
ungeimpfte wir haben sehr viele vor
erkrankte bei denen es die durchbrüche
gibt was auch zu erwarten war weil man
wird nicht stil gekämpft und wir haben
einen extremen mangel an pflegepersonal
in vielen kliniken deswegen haben wir
einfach weniger betten die zu heißt es
dann im amtsdeutsch gepflegt werden
können also die betten sind zwar da aber
der pfleger die man dazu braucht oder
die pfleger die sind halt nicht darum
die rund um die uhr zu betreuen und das
führt zu einem problem nicht
flächendeckend wirklich nicht
flächendeckend wir haben nicht
deutschlandweit ein großes problem wir
haben probleme in einigen regionen noch
können patienten einfach verlegt werden
das war zum beispiel auch das was bodo
ramelow der ministerpräsidenten
thüringens freitag sehr unglücklich
ausgedrückt hat um es mal so zu sagen
sehr unglücklich ausgedrückt drückt hat
gemeint hatte er offenbar dass nicht
mehr alle patienten in thüringen
behandelt werden werden können dann
müssen sie halt in nachbarländer kommen
oder in andere regionen aber wir haben
keinen flächendeckenden notstand wir
müssen aber zuhören wenn einzelne
kliniken einzelnen regionen jetzt alle
angeschlagen das kann heissen muss nicht
es kann heißt er hat halt das alles hin
kommt er hat halt eingeteilt in geimpft
und wir ja im übrigen voll sein handeln
hier in thüringen nur noch wissen
gedämpften deswegen sag ja er hat
unglücklich und du sagst sehr
unglücklich und damit hast du recht
ausgedrückt also komplett verquer
ausgedrückt aber wir müssen zumindest
hinhören wenn in einigen regionen alarm
geschlagen wird es kann sein dass das
sich ausbreitet und dass das eher
schlimmer wird aber flächendeckend haben
wir das problem noch nicht wir holen
sagte andreas gassen dazu in unsere
unterhaltung er ist der
vorstandsvorsitzende der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
einen schönen guten tag ihnen guttenberg
hallo wenn sie die zahlen hören die wir
hier gerade diskutiert haben macht ihnen
das sorgen
das kann man schon da muss man schon
sehr kritisch darauf schauen das ist ja
keine schöne entwicklung selbst wenn die
zahlen mit corona intensivpatienten im
frühjahr zum teil doppelt so hoch ist
das natürlich schon ein warnsignal weil
wir müssen ja davon ausgehen dass wir
wenn das sich so weiter fortsetzt wir
anfangen müssen tatsächlich routine
effektiv operationen in den
krankenhäusern die potenzielle intensiv
aufenthalt nach sich ziehen wieder zu
verschieben das ist ja das was wir im
letzten winter gemacht haben das tut mir
bisher nicht und das ist natürlich für
die menschen die es betrifft schon
erhebliche problematik von daher müssen
wir schon auf diese zahlen durchaus
kritisch und sorgenvoll schauen das
kommt in eine zeit in der man dann so
viele sachen wieder nicht kapiert
vergassen einerseits sagt die ampel die
epidemische notlage soll enden andere
sagen wir müssen die unbedingt
verlängern die einen schauen auf die
inzidenz die jetzt bundesweit wieder
rauf sind auf über 200 absoluter
rekordwert die anderen sagen guckt dann
nicht auf die inzidenz werte zu stark
jetzt gucken wir die krankenhäuser geht
schlägt das erste krankenhaus alarm was
es so die eine zahl oder der eine blick
der ihnen die lage an diesem montag am
klarsten erklärt leider gibt es die eine
zahlen nicht das problem mit der
beendigung der epidemischen lage
nationaler tragweite ist ja mehr ein ein
normen geben das problem man hat diese
regelung eingeführt damit der
bundesminister über verordnungen
regieren kann jetzt kann man durchaus
das lassen muss aber dann in den
jeweiligen ländern natürlich regelungen
schaffen wie die im zweifel auf
situationen reagieren denn wir haben an
der karte vor hingesehen die belastung
der einzelnen bundesländer ist extrem
unterschiedlich insofern ist glaube ich
eine einheitliche vorgehensweise nicht
zielführend vom grundsätzlichen dingen
mal abgesehen aber muss natürlich
beispielsweise thüringen sachsen bayern
härter nach steuern als in
schleswig-holstein sofern die eines
tages gibt es nicht jens spahn hat mal
vor ein paar wochen flapsig gesagt 200
ist das neue 50 das stimmt in teilen wir
haben natürlich die inzidenz auch
getrieben durch sehr hohe zahlen bei den
kindern und jugendlichen aber trotzdem
steigt natürlich auch den eltern
altersgruppen an und wir haben eben
immer noch einen relativ hohen anteil
von nicht geimpften 3 millionen über 60
jährige und das sind natürlich auch die
menschen die wir auf intensivstationen
nach einigen wochen infektion dann
wieder sehen und das ist natürlich
schon eine eine situation die man kaum
nachvollziehen kann wir haben einen
wirksamen infektionen für alle kostenlos
und es gibt einen großen teil immer noch
der diese option nicht zieht
sie sprechen gerade von denen die die
option nicht ziehen wie hoch schätzen
sie den prozentsatz der einfach nicht
bereit ist sich impfen zu lassen und wie
groß ist das problem dass durch diese
menschen entsteht
es gibt im prinzip zwei untersuchungen
die das jetzt noch mal abgefragt haben
eine aus erfordert eine jetzt die
forsa-umfrage man muss davon ausgehen
dass von den bisher nicht geimpften doch
der größte teil ca 80 prozent schlicht
impf unwillig ist und nicht oder
praktisch nicht zu überzeugen ist einen
kleinen teil der bisher nicht geben über
18 irgendwen wir noch erreichen das muss
man versuchen da muss man auch
niederschwellige angebote machen aber es
ist in der tat für mich auch schwer
nachvollziehbar es gibt einen nicht
unerheblichen teil der bevölkerung
der aus welchen gründen auch immer sich
nicht impfen lassen möchte weil sie
vielleicht einmal ein crooner gibt es
nicht wirklich oder sie kriegen chip
implantiert die
begründung sieht ja zum teil absurd und
das ist ein problem weil das sind die
menschen die die intensivstation füllen
neben denen und das in deutlich
geringerem umfang sehr alten patienten
oder immungeschwächten die eben
durchbrüche erleiden lassen sie uns über
die alten und auch über die jungen
sprechen schützen wir denn die derzeit
genug wir sehen besonders ausbrüche
jetzt bei kindern gelingt es uns auch
gleichzeitig jetzt die alten zu schützen
ganz konkret auch die frage braucht man
eine impfpflicht für pflegepersonal
beispielsweise in altenheim
ja das ist ein politisch entscheidenden
pflicht also ich muss gestehen als
mediziner habe ich wenig verständnis
dafür über einen patienten kontakt habe
das nicht geimpft in meinem
medizinischen umfeld sind alle herzlich
oder pflegerisches personal insofern ist
das schwierig auch damals hatte
schwierige personelle situation in den
pflegeheimen und wahrscheinlich ist es
sogar so dass was man jetzt zunehmend
hört dass er die hilfskräfte nicht geben
und die richtigen pflegekräfte
examinierten pflegekräfte sehr wohl also
das ist schwierig eine impfpflicht muss
dann im zweifel politisch entschieden
werden mit den kindern haben sie
angesprochen und das ist so daher extrem
hohe inzidenz und das ist auch nicht
völlig überraschend sehen allerdings
berlin kinder praktisch keine schweren
erkrankung das ist insofern das positive
daran deshalb muss man es nicht ich kann
das nicht ignorieren weil es ist ja auch
nicht ausschließen dass zumindest ein
kleiner teil möglicherweise
langzeitschäden oder langzeit folgen
erläutert schäden die dauerhaft beim
wohl eher nicht aber doch die einige
wochen und monate die kinder noch
beeinträchtigen können sofern muss man
das schauen aber sehr viel kritischer
ist die situation bei den ganz alten
weil die eben dann sehr häufig auch
schwere verläufe haben und eben auch zu
tode kommen und wir haben früher bis zu
1000 todesfälle am tag gehabt da sind
wir gott sei dank mit etwas über 30 40
heute weit von entfernt aber es ist
natürlich
anzustreben das versuchen die zahl
möglichst niedrig zu halten und das
gelingt wenn wir jetzt tatsächlich
die booster impfung bei den von der
stiko empfohlene personen durchführen
das läuft ja schon einige millionen sind
ja auch schon gebucht hat und das
geringe bis zum ende des jahres denke
ich auch hin sie haben es gerade schon
angesprochen wenn wir die leute bewusst
an die stiko empfehlungen haben das sind
nicht sonderlich viele das sind die
alten das sind die über 70-jährigen oder
sind leute mit immunschwächen zum
beispiel jetzt hat gesundheitsminister
sparen appelliert und zwar nicht nur an
die bundesländer sondern auch
ausdrücklich an ihre ärzte also an die
niedergelassenen ärzte doch zu boostern
und zwar jeden der will und jeden der
fünf bis sechs monate rum hat dürfen sie
die überhaupt mustern und warum gibt es
dann die berichtet dass die leute nach
hause geschickt werden von den ärzten
also das muss man glaube ich etwas
auseinander ziehen die stiko empfehlung
umfasst eben dem personenkreis gehen sie
genannt haben zusätzlich diejenigen nur
eine johnson johnson kommt da reden wir
von 15 millionen menschen die bis zum
jahresende geimpft werden so wenige sind
das nicht die
impfverordnung gibt im grundsatz eine
möglichkeit dass alle die ihre impfung
sechs monate oder länger hinter sich
haben sich eine auffrischimpfung holen
können wir aus medizinischer sicht sehen
aber schon einen klaren priorität
unterschied es ist dringend notwendig
die von der stiko definierte gruppe
zügig zu boostern weil die eben im
durchbrüche erleiden in höherem umfang
und dann auch schwere verläufe erreichen
ob es grundsätzlich sinnvoll ist dass
man 18 20 30 40 jährige die an im schutz
haben booster werden die studien
auswertung den nächsten wochen und
monaten zeigen im moment haben die aber
keinen dringenden booster bedarf das ist
so ein bisschen als wenn sie beim in der
personengruppe als 35-jähriger folge im
stau dann wären der booster impfung als
wenn sie gürtel und hosenträger tragen
brauchen tun sie das im moment nicht es
ist ja auch nicht so dass der impfschutz
nach sechs monaten wie bei einem
streaming abo plötzlich weg ist sondern
der beginnt nach zuerst im grundsatz
beginnt er damit ja schon wenige wochen
nach der zweiten impfung aber ist auch
nach sechs monaten bei der
normalbevölkerung noch so hoch dass die
gut geschützt sind und deshalb glauben
wir und das ist auch die position der
stiko das weh prioritär jetzt zügig die
gruppe impfen die von den booster davon
am meisten profitiert und am
gefährdetsten für schwere verläufe ist
wenn man dann ob man die grenzen über 70
oder bei 60 zieht das ist dann fast
schon akademisch insofern glaube ich
dass das wird so kleinteilig auch keiner
beurteilen
aber es ist glaube ich nicht zielführend
wenn wir jetzt mit appellen insbesondere
die jungen zur booster impfung wollen
bevor wir die alten alle durch haben und
das glaube ich dass wir wirklich mir
auch ein dringendes anliegen und wichtig
ist dafür auch dass wir zu einem
vernünftigen einladungsverfahren sei es
durch die gemeinden durch die
gesundheitsämter durch die krankenkassen
kommen damit die menschen die für eine
busse impfung prioritär in frage kommen
davon auch erfahren dass können die
arztpraxen aus verschiedensten gründlich
leisten ist mir das logistische aufwand
zweitens kennen wir ja auch nicht alle
menschen aus diesen personen bei denen
nicht zwangsläufig in den praxen sind
also von daher das muss von der
öffentlichen hand oder von den
krankenkassen gemacht werden jetzt haben
sie sich ja gerade noch mal geärgert
auch über all die die eben noch keine
impfung haben so viele ärgern sich über
diese allerdings nicht mit dem ergebnis
dass die sich jetzt ganz schnell impfen
lassen also dieses ärgernis führt
offenbar nicht zur impfung dann der welt
ärztechef der hat sich gestern ganz
besonders geärgert in der sendung anne
will und hat von einer tyrannei der
ungeimpften gesprochen eine tyrannei der
ungeimpften also bedeutet das sagte mich
frank ulrich montgomery dass diejenigen
die noch nicht geimpft sind den anderen
aktuell die probleme schaffen den
anderen die regeln aufdrücken usw finden
sie dieses zitat tyrannei der
ungeimpften finden sie das passend
helgason
es ist sehr plastisch und sehr drastisch
aber
kein rauch ohne feuer natürlich haben
wir die probleme die wir jetzt haben
eben im wesentlichen tatsächlich durch
den noch relativ großen anteil der nicht
geimpften erwachsenen das muss man
betonen kinder und jugendliche sind ja
nicht die treiber die die krankenhäuser
und intensivstationen schön also die
intensivstation füllen sich mit
erwachsenen überwiegend hatte ich auch
mit älteren erwachsenen die nicht
geimpft sind das ist eine ganz plumpe
war das muss man einfach so deutlich
sagen neun von zehn dieser intensiv
patienten sind nicht geimpft die anderen
sind die hochbetagten mit ihnen mit mit
durchbrüchen und insofern muss man sagen
wenn wir eine höhere impfquote hätten
hätten wir viele der probleme und auch
vor allem wenn diese zahlen natürlich
also fühlen sich vielleicht ein bisschen
drastisch aber inhaltlich muss man sagen
richten wir uns natürlich nach den
angeblichen klar herzlichen dank für das
gespräch andreas gassen der chef der
kassenärztlichen
bereitschaftsdienst von ungeimpften
alle tyrannei ist er wirklich ein sehr
großes wort ich sag mal da hat jemand
wirklich deutlich ganz nach oben dann im
regal gegriffen wo man einfach alle drei
etagen tiefer sicher bedienen können es
ist natürlich ärgerlich man darf sich
daran aber nicht jeder muss sich impfen
lassen sind es ist ein freies land und
da darf man sich ärgern darf man sich
man darf auch mieten seien aber von
tyrannei reden geht für mich einfach
schon zu weit